It's,
it's not until book three of Paradise lost that the poet explicitly reveals to
us,
to his readers,
the fact of the physical handicap that might reasonably be thought to render
impossible.
His,
his composition of the poem.
It's not until book three until after Milton presents his heroic is heroic
portrait of Satan.
It's Aurora portrait of the fallen angels as he establishes the,
when he establishes the fact of his blindness.
And so I'm dividing,
um,
I'm going to be devoting this lecture to Milton's representation of his
blindness and especially to that,
to the invocation of light with which book three begins.
Because I'm absolutely convinced that a feeling for the phenomenon of,
of Milton's blindness is crucial to any real understanding of,
of,
of this poem,
certainly,
but also of this poet.
And so one of the questions that I want here to pursue is the question why
Milton,
with the exception of a,
an oblique.
And it's really a very old bleak reference in the opening and vocation,
why Milton waits until now,
until the third book of his epic to divulge his blindness to his reader.
So Milton began,
uh,
Milton began to lose his eyesight around 1646.
This is when he's in his,
uh,
his late thirties,
and he was entirely blind by February of 1652.
And that was at the age of 44,
according to one of the earliest biographers and really usefully and wonderfully
merit cues includes in the back of the hues edition.
Um,
most of the earliest biographies of Milton.
And they make first Scott found fascinating reading.
These are sketches of the poet written very shortly after Milton's death.
According to one of these biographers,
Milton subjected himself to a range of medical procedures in order to,
to cure,
or at least to forestall the young con,
the,
the darkness that was about to,
to,
to set over him.
He imbibed a lot of,
a lot of potent medicines.
Um,
obviously they were ineffective and he endured the indignity of that procedure
that was most commonly deployed in the 17th century for the treatment of any
serious disease.
And that was the process of bloodletting.
And so we have to imagine that Milton,
as did other,
uh,
other men and women who underwent,
some,
uh,
some onset of blindness,
um,
small incisions would be made in the skin around Milton's eyes and a quantity of
blood would be drained at regular intervals in order to empty the body of the
harmful toxins.
Or it's a ill humors that were believed to produce,
uh,
this,
this terrible malady.
The medical community,
of course,
was not able to forestall the failure of Milton's eyes.
And so as I said,
Milton was blind by 1652.
Milton would never see his fourth child,
a daughter born three months after the onset of total blindness he would never
see the face of is never again see the face of his wife,
Mary Powell,
when she died three days after the child's birth.
Nor could he witnessed the death of his only son,
John Jr,
which occurred six weeks after that.
And finally,
Milton would never see the face of Catherine Woodcock,
the woman he married four years later and who soon herself died in childbirth.
Nor would he ever see the face of Elizabeth Mitchell who we married nine years
after that.
Um,
why,
why did,
why did Milton go blind?
Reasonable conjecture leads us to think that it was either glaucoma or
cataracts,
but of course our business here has nothing to do with the real represent,
with a real causes of,
of Milton's blindness.
But with Milton's literary figuration,
his representation of the causes of his blindness.
And I,
and I'm convinced that one of the most powerful determinants in Milton's late
writings is the drive Milton's drive to ascertain and then also to justify the
cause of his life,
loss of sight.
And I think you have throughout,
throughout the late writings,
a really a proliferation of explanations and justifications,
um,
of his blindness.
And they really feel Milton's Milton's writing throughout the entire period from
1652 his death in 1674.
First let us consider how Milton's contemporaries interpreted his blindness.
Ah,
Milton's Milton's world fell into total darkness a little,
little less than a year after he finished his great and really quite daring
political treatise.
The first defense of the English people,
which was,
which was published in 1651 this was the last of Milton's regicide treatises.
It was written in Latin because the new Commonwealth government had had
commissioned Milton commissioned John Milton to justify the unprecedented act of
regicide to the entire European community,
which is why Milton didn't write it in English.
Milton was responsible for explaining to all of Europe why the English people
had beheaded their king and why they had set up a new government on what Milton
considered to be idealistic non monarchic principles.
Now Mountain,
most of Milton's readers on the continent were appalled,
appalled by England's action and appalled,
especially by Milton's defense of England.
And it was widely thought that not only on the continent,
but also by Milton's,
a lot of Milton's fellow Englishman,
it was widely thought that God
had blinded Milton specifically for his writing against the king.
Milton was the subject of a number of sermons,
sermons that were delivered from the pulpits by,
by conservative Anglican Churches,
uh,
and the,
and the sermons pointed to Milton as an example.
Milton was an example.
Look what happens to those who lift their hand against God's anointed king.
Look,
look what happened to Milton.
He was punished with blindness for riding his defense of the regicide.
And it's in response to just this type of common accusation that Milton writes,
that a lovely sonnet to his friend.
Uh,
Mr Syriac Skinner,
uh,
this is on page 170 in the Hughes.
This is the Sonnet in which Milton insists justice.
He will in a second defense of the English people that is blind.
It has nothing whatsoever to do with an act of God.
So in the,
in the poet to to Tuh Syriac Skinner,
Milton's been totally blind for about three years now.
And he begins this sonnet to his friend like this Syriac this three years day,
these eyes though,
clear to outward view of blemish or of spot bereft of light.
They're seeing have forgot
and Milton rights repeatedly that,
that through throughout this period that despite his blindness,
his eyes appear,
and this is incredibly important to him.
They appear to outward view to be perfectly healthy.
And he continually clears himself of any wrong doing by insisting that his eyes
are clear of blemish or spot or any sign that is,
I,
I have to assume of sin or,
or of corruption or blame.
And so far from being robbed of light by God,
his eyes of simply,
and isn't this a lovely metaphor?
His lies of his eyes had simply forgotten how to see.
And,
and you'll remember how important,
how redemptive actually the idea of forgetting had become a to Milton in
paradise lost.
Now Milton goes even further in the sonnet an exculpating himself.
Look at line 10.
This is when he,
this is where he claims that he has supported by his conscience,
his knowledge,
that he willingly sacrificed his eyes for the patriotic goal of,
of political liberty.
And so Milton is,
is talking of his eyes here.
I lost them over,
applied in Liberty's defense,
my noble task of which all Europe talks from side to side.
Uh,
he,
he ruined his eyesight with the,
with the tireless Labor that he had devoted to the two writing that first
defense of the English people.
Milton sacrificed his eyes for the freedom of his countrymen,
the,
the noble task for which he was compensated.
He was compensated with the talk of all of Europe.
He was a celebrity.
And according to this formulation,
Milton has knowingly and willingly bought fame as a political liberator with
the,
with the noble sacrificial payment of his eyes.
Now this is the claim at Milton is making publicly in these poems,
um,
in,
in this period.
And,
and,
and in the pros treatise is,
and it's a claim for the nobility of the tragic condition that he finds himself
in.
And so when all of Milton's public poetry and prose,
Milton asserts his blindness as a point of pride.
He and he even go so far in the second defense of the English people to claim
that is blindness is actually a sign of God's election.
Uh,
God has,
God has chosen him.
And it's an incredibly beautiful image.
The image of Milton's eyes being covered by heavenly wings,
by angel wings almost as a favor.
Um,
he's continually asserting publicly.
That is blindness is a sign of strength,
but we have a more,
we have a more private and a more personal consideration of his blindness and a
letter that Milton wrote to his friend,
a Dr. Leonard for Loris.
Um,
the Athenian.
Uh,
and this was in the packet in the more in the more private venue of the personal
letter.
Milton seems in some ways to lower his guard and he makes a powerful and moving
plea for a cure because he's writing to a doctor.
And so look at the look in the packet.
Um,
this is around page 60 in the packet.
The,
the,
the original page number is seven 22,
I believe Milton's articulating here for the doctor,
the history of his loss of sight and the nature of his condition.
It is 10 years,
I think more or less since I noticed my site becoming weak and growing dem.
And at the same time my spleen and all my viscera are burdened and shaken with
flatulence.
And so after this account of,
of intestinal discomfort,
Milton then describes the mist that began to appear in his left eye,
which is Milton's left.
I was the first one to fail.
And then a few,
a few sentences down.
He describes the failure of the right eye,
the other eye,
also failing slowly and gradually over a period of almost three years,
some months before my site was completely destroyed,
everything which I distinguished when I myself was still seem to swim now to the
right now to the left,
certain permanent vapers seem to have settled upon my entire forehead and
temples,
which press and Oh,
press my eyes with this sort of sleepy heaviness,
especially for mealtime to evening
and mill.
In this letter to the doctor,
uh,
Milton associates,
the onsite of his blonde,
the onset of his blindness with the onset of a gastrointestinal complaint.
And,
uh,
and in doing this,
he's following the common wisdom about the causes of blindness,
which was usually attributed in the scientific community of the 17th century,
uh,
to,
to a digestive problem.
And so for Milton is most depressive pain,
burdened his forehead and his eyes in the hours following the noontime meal.
And this pain corresponded.
The pain in his head corresponded to a pain in his gut,
uh,
which,
which occurred presumably in the same hours following the noontime male a meal
as his,
as his entire frame was shaken with a violent flatulence.
And,
and,
and this is how the theory of this kind of digestive ailment caused blindness.
Um,
the,
the digestive vapors that Milton or,
or anyone who was going blind was not able to expel successfully for through,
uh,
through normal digestion.
And the normal process of the passing of wind of these vapors were trapped in
the,
in our poets body.
They began gradually to rise up to his head over a period of many months or even
years where they settled into the sockets of his eyes and eventually they
clouded over his eyes and cut off all access to light from the outside.
Uh,
another way of putting this,
the,
the affliction that would alter forever,
the last quarter of Milton's life had its ultimate cause in the process of,
of digestion.
And Milton's greatest misery was quite simply the consequence.
And he may have believed this,
the consequence of something he ate.
Now you are,
you've probably,
if you've no doubt gas,
why I'm emphasizing this particular figuration of Milton's blindness as an
irrevocable change,
uh,
that that follows the ingestion of food.
The,
the story of Milton's blindness as he represents.
It's brings us so perilously close to the story of the fall,
which is of course another narrative that imagines the in alterable and terrible
effects of something eaten at one critic William Kerrigan has called,
uh,
you know,
in a,
in his brilliant analysis in the book,
the Sacred Complex has called paradise lost the story of an evil meal.
And it's important in the poem that Adam and Eve fall at noon.
The forbidden fruit is there noontime meal.
And it's possible that Kerrigan has right into aligning the dynamics of the loss
of paradise with,
with the logic that Milton employees and describing the loss of his site.
And when Adam falls in book nine of Paradise lost.
Um,
and these are the lines that are behind me on the board here.
we have a description of the almost physiological response of the earth to the
sinful transgression of Adam and eve.
Adam Earth trembled from her end trails as again in pangs and nature gave his
second grown.
It's as if Milton has transposed onto the entire earth the,
the digestive pains that were the consequences of his own noontime meal as if
the flatulent earth were responding sympathetically to the violent shaking of
Milton's own end trails.
No.
Now we now,
now we're left at the point that we're so often left.
What's the,
what's the point of all of this?
What's at stake or what might be at stake in this connection between Milton's
own,
a postprandial groaning and moaning and the,
and the,
and the even more poignant posts,
lapse area and groaning of Adam and eve,
Adam and eve and the entire earth.
Now the connection between these two phenomena,
I believe if there is one in involves transgression,
the physical deterioration that visits human beings after the fall comes as a
direct consequence of course as their transgression of divine law.
And it's possible that we have buried in this narrative of Milton's own physical
deterioration and related narrative of,
of kind of transgression and,
and punishment.
And,
and I,
I assume that it has already become clear to you that this will be one of those
lectures that I'm giving over entirely to perfectly shameless,
uh,
biographical speculation.
And it's one of the great joys and I take it to be one of the great privileges
of being able to lecture on Milton,
um,
and in this format rather than it is in a seminar format.
Because of course,
if this were a seminar,
you could and you would be right to ask me for my proof.
How do I know,
uh,
what Milton was thinking?
And of course I have,
I have no proof.
But I know what I believe and I'm going,
I'm willing here at now to share with you these things that I believe actually
quite,
quite passionately and my own belief is that on some level,
Milton may not have convinced himself when he wrote in the second defense or
Milton may not have convinced himself when he wrote in that Sonnet to Mr Syriac
Skinner,
that he had willingly sacrificed his eyes for the good,
for the good of his country,
or that God had permitted his blindness as a sign of his special election
covering his eyes with with Angel Wings.
It's possible that what you were having a letter like the letter to Leonard
Floris is,
is something like a submerged expression of,
of guilt.
Maybe Milton's enemies were right.
Maybe Milton was,
maybe Milton was to blame with his transgressive challenges to every conceivable
form of authority.
Maybe Milton was to blame for his blindness,
the affliction that God visited upon him for his,
for his crimes.
Now this is of course just one.
This is just one way to understand the extraordinary attention that Milton gives
to his blindness in the invocation to book three of his epic,
uh,
turned to page 257 in the Hughes,
Milt Milton continues in paradise lost.
This is written well after well over a decade after the onset of blindness,
Milton continues to defend himself from the imputation of blame.
The,
the,
the Muse Milton invokes here is,
is,
is not the traditional muse of the classic epic or even the Heavenly Muse that
Milton seems to have fashioned in the first in vocation.
It's now that power.
It's exactly that power from which Milton has been excluded by virtue of his
blindness,
light,
hail,
holy light,
offspring of heaven,
firstborn,
or of the eternal coeternal beam.
May I express the unblend blamed?
Let me just stop right there.
May I express the unblend Milton Milton's exposing a few at the very beginning
here of some imputation of blame or,
or,
or guilt.
He and he's not even sure how to address this inspiring light.
The first,
the first seven lines of this invocation aren't,
are not just to the most,
and they are,
they are,
but they are not simply the most impenetrable lines and the entire poem.
They are among the most difficult lines of poetry ever written.
And,
and it's always worth asking why a passage of poetry is so impossible to wrap
your brain around.
What's at stake here in this difficulty?
Why this struggle and why,
why was Milton struggle with such awkward minute metaphysical categories in
order simply to address properly the power,
the power of light?
I think it's understandable that Milton would call the power of light offspring
of heaven,
firstborn.
Uh,
according to Genesis,
light is the first thing that is created at the,
at the,
at,
at the moment of God's Fiat Lux.
Let,
let there be light that command that great commandment.
But the problem really arises in line too,
when Milton conjectures that the beam of light he's addressing wasn't born or
wasn't but gotten at all,
it wasn't created that it might actually be co eternal with the eternal father
himself.
And,
and this I think is a much more dangerous possibility.
Milton asks to be enlightened by a light that might be as old as the father.
This runs an utterly counter to the creation account in genesis.
Uh,
could this light be one of the fathers rivals?
And there's a fear here that the ambition of this bid for paternal light is
presumptuous.
Perhaps it's even satanic.
Satan,
of course,
in the next book book four,
we'll have his invocation to light.
Now the light Milton addresses has been around forever.
Look at line eight of this opening in vocation.
This,
this is on the next page.
Okay.
Before the Sun,
before the heavens,
thou worked.
And at the voice of God,
as with the Mantel did invest the rising world of waters,
dark and deep.
One from the form one from the void and formless infinite
Viv revisit now with boulder wing,
escaped this Digi and pool the long detained in that sojourn well in my flight
through other and through middle darkness,
born with other notes.
Then to the your Feehan liar.
I Sung of chaos and eternal night,
taught by the heavenly muse to venture down the dark descent and up to reascend
though hard and rare,
Milton's giving us a picture of himself as,
as as proud clean.
He clearly,
he's proud that he's returned from the descent into hell that he seems to have
made during the composition of the first two books of his epic's.
He himself has escaped this Daejeon pool and such a reassessment is hard and
rare,
but,
but we've just had represented before this at the very end of the book to just
Lonnie was before this Satan's own escape from this Daejeon pool and Satan's own
detainment in his obscure sojourn through chaos.
And there's a,
there's a remarkable identification that Milton is bringing himself very close,
close to an identification between Milton and Satan,
and there lingers in this,
in this relation to the idea that Milton has brought upon himself some,
some guilt,
some blame perhaps for having Sung of Heaven,
no for having Sung of hell and having sung of chaos at all.
Now,
Milton of course doesn't,
he can't make this connection explicit,
but their alerts the possibility,
and I grant you that it's an irrational possibility that,
that Milton has done something wrong.
I don't know how else to read these lines as if he were,
had done something wrong by flying through UTR and through middle darkness
during his composition of the first two books of paradise lost.
It's,
it's,
it's almost as if,
and I know this doesn't make sense,
it's almost as if Milton's flight through darkness had been responsible for the
literal visual darkness.
That is the condition of his blindness,
which he is describing now to us for the first time.
It's,
it's this possibility.
I think that the,
the idea that Milton has brought his blindness on,
on himself over the course of the composition of the poem,
which of course this isn't the case,
it's this possibility that I think accounts for the delay in Milton's Milton's
mention of his loss of sight,
the delay until this moment in the poem.
It is,
it the guilt for his blindness in some impossible way lay in the composition of
this very poem as if the transgression,
transgression that called down the wrath of the heavenly father had been
Milton's glorious and heroic treatment of,
of Satan as if it were Milton's ambitious attempt to supply the angelic
prehistory to the,
to the,
to the book of Genesis to the creation account that we get in the book of
Genesis that had brought this wrath upon him.
Milton preempt and he prevented genesis.
Okay.
He continues his address to the light,
the eye,
the eye revisit safe and feel by sovereign vital lamp.
But thou revisit snob these eyes,
that role in vain to find by piercing ray and find no dawn.
Okay,
so thick,
a drop,
serene,
have quenched their orbs or dims a fusion veiled
like so many of the lines in this vocation.
These lines are,
are violently crammed with an almost unbearable pathos.
Um,
it's,
it's impossible to read these lines.
The,
I revisit safe,
but thou revisits not these eyes.
It's impossible to read these lines and not feel that Milton is in some way
accusing the deity of,
of injustice.
It's as if Milton,
we're challenging the holy light to revisit Milton just as Milton is revisiting
the holy light and any,
any structures,
this challenge,
it's,
it's the logic of a quid pro quo here.
He's seeking compensation for his loss,
but the compensation that he's looking for isn't forthcoming.
At least it's not forthcoming yet.
Line 32
nor sometimes,
nor sometimes do I forget those other two equaled with me and fate.
So we're,
I equal with them in renown.
And here he lists the famous blind bards,
the blind profits of the western tradition,
asking the Muse of light to repay him for his fate.
The fate of blindness with fame renown,
uh,
the,
the renowned or fame enjoyed by buying blind Tom Morris and blind.
My on it is my honor.
These is homer and tiger ECS and,
and Phineas Milton knows perfectly well,
perfectly well the,
each of these figures had been blinded as some sort of punishment for a crime,
at least according to most of the legends surrounding them.
Each of these years was thought to have been blinded for aspiring to an intimate
knowledge of the godhead.
And even as,
as as,
as Milton is asking God to elevate him to the status of their equal and equal to
homer,
sharing an equal renown on an equal fame,
he's implicitly acknowledging that terrifying possibility.
And it really is terrifying that that his blind is like theirs is,
is the result of,
of his own trans a transgression,
his punishment for trespassing on,
on divinity.
But this acknowledgement if,
if,
if it is,
and I think it is,
this acknowledgment of guilt only takes place between the lines below the
surface of the,
in vocation.
And for the most part,
Milton is struggling to clear himself from any imputation of sin or crime and so
from,
so from lines 40 to 50 that the strategy of this invocation shifts again and
Milton catalogs the losses that he has endured through the,
the,
the loss of his sight
when before had a poet
represented himself in such,
in such heartbreaking lines.
Thus with the year seasons return,
but not to me returns day or the suite approach of even or mourn or side of
vernal bloom or summers rose or Fox or herds or human face divine.
But cloud instead and ever during dark surrounds me from the cheerful ways of
men cut off
a few poets have been willing even well after Milton had been willing to subject
themselves to this kind of absolutely pathos filled self representation and for
and for exposing himself in all of his vulnerability.
Milton is taking,
he has everything to lose here and for exposing himself in all of his
vulnerability.
Milton asks for something in return,
he asks to be recompensed for these extraordinary losses.
And there I am.
I'm absolutely convinced that there's a way in which this request is not
irrational.
It's completely reasonable because he is bathed himself in a pathos.
I think that's almost too,
uh,
too painful even to read.
We as readers are willing,
we're willing to grant him anything,
anything he wants.
There's a kind of naked emotional logic.
It's a governing our experience of these lines.
Let's look at the moment at which Milton asks for the payback.
This is line 51
I have lost all these things so much.
The rather thou so much the rather val celestial light shine inward and the mind
through all her powers,
your radiate,
their plant eyes.
Milton is demanding for his pains,
the inspiration of the heavenly muse.
God,
God owes him this.
And so Milton is,
is,
is remarkably undoing the logic of sin and punishment that he had inherited in
his understanding of his blindness.
And he's,
and he's restructuring it as something entirely different.
He's turning it into a logic of loss and compensation.
Milton has sacrificed his site.
He has lost almost everything and so much the rather that's God repay him for
that.
Lost his noble.
But is once again his noble self sacrifice and you have Milton reworking,
hear the rhetoric of guilt,
um,
his and in his blind is becomes important.
Not because it's a sign of punishment or a blame or a spot or blemish,
but it's a bit,
it's a guarantee of this,
uh,
of the,
inspirational success of the poem.
And this is like a promissory note is blindness,
is for his poetic reward.
The fact that this poem we'll have been inspired by the heavenly muse.
A look,
oh,
this is wonderful.
Turn to the very last page of hues of,
of the merit cubes edition.
This is page 1044.
This is one of the earliest biographies of Milton,
uh,
written in the 17th century and it's an anonymous one and it gives us some
remarkable details about this man's life.
Some of them are so,
uh,
so astonishing.
There's no way they could have been made up.
The writer at the,
uh,
the anonymous writer at the top of page 1044 is describing Milton's daily habits
as he was composing Paradise Lost Paradise lost in the later poems.
And Milton,
it seems would dictate the most recent.
Every man would dictate the most recent installment of paradise lost in the
morning.
So this is the,
what we learn.
He waking early and you'll see this wonderful admiration of the deer,
Puritan Melton,
waking early as is the use of temperate men had commonly a good stock of versus
ready against his Emmanuel insists came and the manual,
this is the secretary,
the,
the young man who had come to Milton's house.
And there were a number of them who would take down dictation.
And Milton seems to have,
Nelson seems to have composed the poem at night in his sleep,
which,
and but the,
the biographer continues,
which if it happened to be later than ordinary,
Milton would complain if the manual sisters,
it's secretary got there too late,
Milton would complain saying he wanted to be milked.
This absolutely stunning biographical detail is italicized here,
presumably because it's a,
it's a quotation and that's a form of noting a quotation.
Uh,
but,
but the metallic seem to me at least to indicate as well that this is an
extraordinary privilege moment in this biographical text.
It's,
it's a scandalous little tidbit.
Um,
if,
uh,
if it's true and we have in here and extraordinary image of Milton's
understanding of his own poetic output,
um,
and if,
if this isn't true,
what we do have here at the very least is an incredibly close and intimate
reading of this very and vocation that we're focusing on having filled himself
up with a stock of versus the night before Milton could imagine himself as a
source of spiritual and,
and poetic nourishment.
Milton could imagine himself the distinctly feminine source of,
of this nourishing poem as if by a process of identification.
So complete Milton could imagine himself in the role of the maternal muse who
feeds the poet as she inspires the thoughts that move harmonious numbers.
That's not the poet.
It's not the muse only,
but the poet to who can be milked.
Now,
God the God the father tells the Sun,
uh,
this is in the dialogue between the father and the son later in book three,
that at the end of time there won't be a father and a son because God shall be
all in all.
And it related form of a kind of absolute internalization.
And absolute identification is at work.
I think in this incredibly moving cry to be milked,
the Muse has so completely inspired the poet,
so completely transferred her power to him that it's be that it's almost
impossible to tell who was who or who is feeding whom.
And when Milton and the invocation requests that the muse,
the holy light feed on thoughts,
we have a moment of a confused confusion that would only seem to guarantee that
the transference of Power Ha has actually taken place.
It doesn't matter whether these thoughts belonged to the muse or to the poet.
These thoughts are all in all.
And,
and you have other guarantees as well.
In book three of Milton's having filled up at the fountain heavenly inspiration,
uh,
and these moments of guarantee come in and extraordinarily,
um,
unexpected places.
Um,
look at book three,
Line Five,
76 in the Hughes edition.
This is page two 72 on his way from hell.
The Earth,
Satan stops at the sun,
which of course is of course the sign,
the source of earthly light.
And Satan watches this as the sun dispenses light to all of the little stars of
having,
this is how Milton's astronomy works,
where the great luminary aloof,
the vulgar constellations thick that the,
of course the great luminary is the son that from his lordly I keeps distance,
do dispenses light from bar.
Now this great luminary that sun dispenses light to the surrounding stars.
And with this image you have a clearly demarcated model of a,
of a particular kind of power relation.
The,
and this is the sun's unilateral,
the powerful sons,
unilateral inspiration of the stars.
But look what happens next.
This is a,
this is the stars.
The,
they,
as they move their story,
dance in numbers that compute days,
months and years toward his old cheering lamp,
turn their various motions that the stars are filling up here with the light of
the sun.
And they,
they're,
they're behaving just as Milton's thoughts do when he's been inspired,
when they have been inspired by holy light,
they're field with the capacity of,
of a kind of freewill.
And they turned themselves in story,
dance.
And Milton is very carefully reworking in this passage,
this,
this astronomical passage of the keywords of the invocation that we've been
looking at move and numbers.
And he projects his image of the inspired composition of the poem onto the
enormous screen of the entire,
of the entire cosmos.
And,
and just as in the invocation,
the actual mover,
the agent behind the action of inspiration is uncertain that they turned swift
their various motions
or are turned by his magnetic beam.
We don't know who's,
we don't know who's turning what.
It's all in all.
And it's as if it's at this moment of uncertain agency that Milton really
consist something truly amazing.
And,
um,
I ask your indulgence here,
okay.
You,
you,
you will know that it's indisputable.
But the point that I'm about to make,
but it's,
um,
it's,
I think it's shocking.
The Sun warms the universe just as the holy light will warm the poet that much I
think is clear.
But Milton's figuration of this process,
this process of is of infusion is truly one of the most surprising moments in
the poem for my money.
This is process of infusion replicates on the grand scale.
Okay,
well,
let,
let me read it first.
Okay.
That beam that gently warms the universe and to each inward part with gentle
penetration though unseen shoots,
invisible virtue,
even to the deep
this,
this process of infusion replicates on the grand scale of the,
of the entire cosmos,
the,
the rhythms of the intimate human act of,
of Coelho ejaculation.
You simply can't deny that that's what's happening here.
And Milton may give us,
uh,
a cosmic image of the process of,
of inspiration.
But this is a process by which the universe and by association,
the poet himself has been feminized and transformed,
transformed mysteriously,
and it's something like the maternal muse,
her herself.
Milton tells us that the beginning of the end of vocation,
that the light to which he prays was present at the creation and maybe that
light was the same as that identifiable with the heavenly spirit in book one who
dove like sets,
rooting on the vast abyss and made,
did pregnant.
And maybe Milton here in book three is imagining himself the glorious recipient
of this remarkable act of divine impregnation.
He's no longer,
he's no longer the vulnerable male poet who's poetic potency,
just like his site can be cut off at whim from the cheerful ways of men cut off.
He,
he's a body impregnated by God.
The universe is a body impregnated by God and perhaps even indistinguishable at
some point from God.
It's a,
he's a figure impervious
to punishment or pain.
The,
the,
the psyche processes and strategies that I've been describing here are clearly
operating at the level of,
of,
of fantasy.
This is wish fulfillment.
Um,
it's certainly not logic and there's no moment in paradise lost at which the
poet will actually present a logical statement concerning this,
uh,
concerning this wish to be absolutely infused with divinity,
to be so divine that he would be in vulnerable to punishment or to be so divine
that he would be invulnerable to the physical humiliation of blindness.
You don't have anything like an explicit statement to that effect and paradise
lost,
but there is elsewhere.
And Milton and I want to draw you to this.
Now there is such an articulation and another poem,
uh,
this is what many scholars believe was the last poem that Milton Road,
Samson agonists,
ds.
And so I'm going to ask you to turn
to page 553 in the Hughes to this passage in Samsung agonists,
ds.
And so even though we don't read the Samsung agonists stays until the end of the
semester,
I want to look at this small section of it now,
since it engages the problem of,
in,
of,
of blindness with as much pathos and as with as much force as anything that
Milton ever wrote.
So Samsung,
you know,
Samson is the biblical hero who strength was bound up in his hair and Samson was
blinded by the Philistines after his hair had been shorn by his treacherous
wife,
Delilah.
Milton calls her Dolly Lock.
Look at,
um,
so look at the Hughes.
This is line a line 80 of Samson.
Milton has,
Milton has his hero,
Samson bill wailing the fact of his blindness.
Oh,
dark,
dark amid the blaze of noon.
Irrecoverably dark total eclipse without all hope of day.
And,
and,
and at this point it's wonderful.
Milton begins to Echo Sampson begins to echo Milton.
I'm from the invocation that we've been looking at the invocation to book three
of paradise.
Lost A,
here's Sampson.
Oh,
first created beam and vow.
Great word.
Let there be light and light was overall.
Why am I thus bereaved thy Prime Decree?
The Sun to me is dark and silent as the moon.
When she desserts the night hid in her vacant inter lunar cave.
Since light,
try to follow this logic since lights so necessary is to life and almost life
itself.
If it be true,
that light is in the soul.
She the sole in all,
she all in every part in Samson's feeling his way here toward Milton's theory of
Mona's them,
the idea that the soul is diffused throughout every part of the human body.
Since the light of the soul is diffused throughout every part of the body.
Why Sampson asks,
why was the site to such a tender ball as the eye can find so obvious and so
easy to be quenched and not as feeling through all parts diffused that she might
look at,
we'll through every poor.
These are extraordinary lines.
These are among my most favorite lines in all of and all of Milton Cep.
Samson is questioning the wisdom and the justice of God's admittedly who can
deny it.
God's extremely peculiar fig configuration of the human body.
Um,
and,
and you read this and you realize that Samson has abs.
He's really on to something here.
Why didn't we ask with Samson,
why didn't God implant the sense of sight and human beings just as he implanted
the sense of touch or feeling what?
Why isn't site like touch diffused through all parts of the body that she might
look at?
We'll through every pore Milton Milton's pushing here toward a,
toward of fantasy of physical invulnerability imagining an alternative.
But this is,
this is science fiction,
I don't know,
alternative model of bodily configuration that would render impossible.
The all to easy quenching of the Tinder eyeballs
in the context of Samson agonists does this particular speech of Samson's,
we have to write it off as a kind of morally suspect complaint and this is a
faithful just questioning of the,
of the justice of God's creation.
And so,
and Milton doesn't permit himself in paradise lost,
at least not explicitly to impugn the wisdom behind God created by Gods of God's
creation of the all too vulnerable human body.
But he does fashion for us.
They're a fantasy and it's a lot in paradise lost and it's a lot like Samson's
fantasy of a body exempt from harm free from disability.
And that is of course the body of the angels.
And so the last passage that I'm going to ask you to look at is on page 331 of
the hues edition.
This is book six,
line three 44.
Um,
and uh,
the,
the narrator here is the Archangel Raphael and Rafiea was explaining to Adam why
the angels and in the war in heaven can't be permanently wounded or harmed.
Now we already know that angels,
we've already learned this,
that angels,
when they please can either sex,
assume or both.
But Raefiel gives us even more information about these perfectly fantastical
creatures.
Their bodies have been constructed along pro precisely those lines that Samson
was proposing.
They're vital functions are diffused through every part.
So look at the bottom of the page.
This is a line three 44,
four spirits that live throughout vital in every part,
not as frail man in end trails,
heart or head,
liver or rains.
These angels cannot,
but by annihilating die,
nor in their liquid texture,
mortal wound receive nor mar can then the fluid air all heart,
they live all head,
all I,
all ear,
all intellect,
all sense
the body of the Ame,
the body of each and every angel has been created.
All in all,
the no sensory power or important function has been confined to a tender ball or
a delicate orb or a particular Oregon.
These,
these angels are all why they have the power of sight diffused throughout their
entire bodies.
And we can only imagine that they can just to,
Samson had fantasize that they can see through every poor.
And so the miltonic angel enjoys the State of absolute site,
an absolute inspiration and absolute oneness with God that Milton has bidding
for.
It's on some level in his complex and ambitious in vocation,
delight in book three and now Milton isn't finished,
uh,
articulating for us the impossible process of his poetic inspiration.
Th th the miracle by which the blind poet is compensated for his blindness with
the vision of things invisible to mortal site and,
and the poem as especially as we will see it in the vocation or the quasi and
vocation to book seven of Paradise lost.
That poem will continue to voice doubts that this process of,
of,
of inspiration has actually occurred.
But you have in the figure of the miltonic angel,
uh,
literalized image,
an embodiment of Milton's most,
most ambitious fantasy for his poem.
Maybe it's not if it's an unrealistic fantasy for himself of course,
but it is an ambitious fantasy in a genuine,
when I think for his poem,
we know that the body of the poet of course would never undergo.
It's much desired,
much fantasize metamorphosis into the body of an angel.
Milton's would never become a body perfected,
rendered impervious to humiliation and darkness,
but the,
but the body of the angel may in the end be an entirely appropriate image for
Milton's,
a fantasy of the body of the poem.
And so it's,
it's this,
it's this perhaps peculiar idea that I'll,
that I'll leave you with today.
If,
if Milton is right,
let's say Milton will grant that Milton is right,
that he was inspired by God to write this poem.
If he is right,
then the body of this epic really is very much like the angelic body.
It is infused and we have to believe that it's infused in every part with the
spirit of God.
And it's nothing less than all heart,
all intellect.
And,
and this is a,
an extraordinarily resonant word from Milton and all sense.
Okay?
That's the,
that's the end of this lecture.
Let me remind you that when you read book three,
four next time,
you will also,
uh,
look at the passages from the Christian doctrine that are assigned on the
syllabus.